11 missiles balistiques chinois a lancé
vers les eaux territoriales taïwanaise
des avions de chasse qui feront la ligne
médiane dans le détroit de taiwan les
exercices militaires sont d'une ampleur
sans précédent des miss et l'ont même
pénétrer la zone économique japonaise
c'est la réponse chinoise promise à la
visite plus tôt cette semaine de nancy
pelosi la présidente de la chambre des
représentants américains
les états unis n'apporte que chaos et
désordre lorsqu'ils disent exprimer leur
solidarité avec un territoire
lance-t-elle la chaîne affirme qu'elle
ne fait que défendre sa souveraineté
elle considère taïwan comme son
territoire et l'ambassadeur chinois en
france par eux-mêmes de rééducation des
taiwanais à venir après la réunification
taiwan condamné qualifie ces tirs de
missiles balistiques d'irrationnel l'élu
dit surveiller de près les exercices
militaires chinois prêt à faire la
guerre sans pour autant la chercher
pour leur part les etats-unis répètent
qu'ils n'ont pas changé leur politique
envers taiwan et il espère que pékin ne
fabriquera pas une crise
si les exercices d'une ampleur jamais
vue font craindre une nouvelle crise
dans le détroit de taiwan sur l'île
l'inquiétude ne semble pas avoir grimpé
à
des exercices militaires chinois prévue
et annoncée plus tôt cette semaine vont
se poursuivre jusqu'à dimanche ici
philippe leblanc radio-canada tainan
dans le sud de l'île de taïwan